to record on computer, so we are recording. Okay, so reading a book about iodide deficiency.
Yes, and I had a goiter that wrapped around my thyroid and ended up having to get them removed.
So, and then I've read iodide deficiency is also linked to breast cancer. So,
where, what do I need to do to see if I still have this? Okay, we should do an iodide test.
So, it's, I think it's about $85. Okay, so we said you the kit, it's a urine test. You said it into the lab,
follow the instructions. We get the results back at about a week and we get to iodine level.
Okay, so it's really important to order that, you know, just call it in an order at or what do I do?
Just call the girls and say, Dr. Cutter said I need an iodide test. It's in the system. They can look it up and
get it right. Okay, great. Thank you. So, real easy. It's good for
and breast cancer patients to do an iodide test. Is it good for everybody? Not necessarily.
Breast cancer patients, yeah, maybe that would be a good idea if I had everybody do what I probably should.
But yeah, that's an easy test to run. Okay, all righty, sounds like a plan.
Okay, we're going to get cooking just so you know you can jump in with questions anytime that we,
that I'm speaking here, don't feel bad about interrupting. Before I get started, when I want to talk
about any other questions from anybody, if this first time you've been on, understand your questions.
Are recorded, so don't ask me anything about your total focus that you know what somebody else
don't want your total focus. So, that will have to be a personal question. So,
and you can jump on and off. And if we get somebody talking in the background, I may mute everyone
and then you can share on this system. I don't know where it is, but here it is. You can share
a question and post it, so I'll unmute you. So, if I hear a lot of talking in the background,
I will mute everybody as we go. Any other questions before we get started and what I wanted to talk about today?
Nothing? Okay, well, today we're going to talk about something that we had some questions come up
about struggling with our emotions through serious illness.
So, I really felt the Lord speak to me this last night and this morning about having to talk
about this today, and it was a very difficult day for me. It just felt very impressive today. It was
a struggle today in a lot of different ways, and I really believe the enemy doesn't want us talking
about this stuff. So, that's why we have to talk about this stuff. So, all of us go through struggles,
and we could call it depression, we could call it sadness, we could call it whatever we want to
call it, but we're not feeling like we're winning the battle. And first of all, we have to understand
that that's adorable, and it's not always normal that we feel victorious in life, and that we're
conquered our demons, and we're conquered what we want, and we're achieving our goals. That just
is not reality. That is not even what is promised in Scripture. So, we are going to have troubles,
and that is really what's promised in Scripture. So, just remember that as we go through this.
So, remember that as you go through life. It's easy to forget that, because we think that we want
to have everything for a while. So, I am hearing some background music heard sound, so I am going to
look at it. I think I just muted myself.
That's not what I wanted to see. Right. So,
or exactly. Yeah, it's a whole different
or getting wet. Sounds like wetty in the background. Oh, I'm just happy you're moving forward.
Okay. So, um, a second, I'm going to stop this. Stop the share and pull this up, and mute all.
Can you guys still hear me? You can speak because I'm just muted everybody.
And now we're going to share this again. So, hopefully everybody can hear me.
I think my mic is still going. So, all right. So, back to this. We're not always feeling great.
We're not always feeling victorious. That's just part of life. But we don't stop there and go,
well, that's just part of life too bad. That's not what I'm talking about. But it's, but don't expect
as a believer that everything's going to be hunky-dory all the time because we're in a battle.
And that's what we're promised is that there's going to be days that are going to be very difficult.
And we look at our Savior in his life. He's a perfect example of that. I mean, he was crying tears
in the garden of assembly. So, we're going to have times if we're going to walk this walk on this earth
that it's not going to be all perfect. So, I'm all for listening to preachers and pastors that are
speaking, you know, positive messages. I like listening to Joel Olstein. But I don't get my theology
from Joel Olstein. So, nothing against Joel Olstein. But I think it's great to have a positive
message and to hear how much God loves us and how much God wants to see our good in our life.
But the fact is, is that we live in a fallen world. And bad things happen to everybody. The rain falls
on the just and the unjust. And rain can sometimes break growth and break wonderful things. But rain can
make messy things and cause flooding too. So, just because it can break blossoms in the end,
it doesn't always mean it's going to feel good right now. So, the fact is, I can have depression.
I can have struggles. So, we want to look at what are some possible causes of that. Because I'm a doctor
because that's what I do. I always want to figure out what the cause is. Plus, I'm a male. I just want
to fix it. So, but I think that's right. I think that we should go, okay, if I am feeling down,
especially for any length of time, even for the day, even today, I was just felt completely oppressed
today. And I had to go to the Lord and say, okay, what is going on here? Is it a metabolic cause?
No, I got to talk several slides about metabolic causes of feeling down. I'll tell you right now,
my oppression today had nothing to do with the metabolic cause. But a person can have metabolic
causes of depression. That's one of the most common causes of depression. There's something
metabolically going on. So, when we talk about metabolic causes of depression, I could talk for hours
on that. So, we just got to kind of sum it up. A person can have variations in their neurotransmitters.
So, that's one piece of a picture of depression is when our dopamine and our serotonin are on
a balance. Typically, both of them are low. And that's what could cause depression. So, if we have
this imbalance in our neurotransmitters and plus done on this slide, glutamate, I can have depression.
I can feel down. Another metabolic cause of depression can be low blood sugar. So,
testing a person's blood sugar, that's something you want to do if I'm really struggling with this
depression. I'm dealing with it from a spiritual perspective. I'm dealing with it from a situational
perspective, but I still have this depression. Now you want to get in and look at some metabolic
things that could be causing that. And if you need help with that, if you're dealing with that,
you need help with that. That's what I'm for. So, that's what my training is in. So, we want to be able
to deal with that as much as possible. So, you need to reach out to me if you're struggling with
something that you just can't get over and you've really feeling down. Now, there's a whole bunch
of genetic pieces to this too. So, we need to take another look at your genes. Just because I took
a mainly bioptic look at your genes about cancer, if you're a cancer patient. Now, we're dealing with
the cancer in every way possible. It doesn't mean other things can't be wrong with the person and other
things can't be going on that we want to address too. Blood sugar issues, neurotransmitter issues,
hormonal issues. Do I have issues with my pituitary and my ovaries? Do I have lower Doritos? Do I
need to deal with thyroid problems? So, I'm well equipped to be able to help you with those things.
You just need to reach out to me. So, don't think that just because you came to me because you have
breast cancer, that I can't help you with these other things. So, do that. Reach out, set up
an appointment, and we'll talk about those things. So, there's metabolic causes certainly to
that could lead to depression. We can never forget, because I tend to forget because I don't
prescribe medication, that drug interactions can be one major cause of a lot of person symptoms.
So, if you're on any medications, make sure that you google that medication and look at any side
effects. So, whether we're talking about depression or whether you're talking about aches or pains
or some weird symptom or a headache or something like that, don't forget to google the medication and
look for possible drug interactions side effects with that medication because many, many times
that is the cause of a person's symptoms. And then you weigh out, well, do I need to be on this
medication or not? Maybe you need to talk to your prescribing doctor to see if you need to change that
or something. So, don't ignore the physical, these metabolic things that are the physical things that
are possible to change, to change how you're feeling instead of just struggling through it and
blaming yourself or something that could just be misery. Of course, when you're going through any
sadness or depression, there could be situational things. There could be stress in our life.
I can't tell you how many times that a cancer patient, and life patients as well, that don't have
a support system behind them that are supporting their decisions in care, that are supporting
them in just, in all the decisions that they're making in their life. I'll tell you many times, you
could have, throughout my 30-some years of practice, that you have a very sick person coming to the
office. I'm not saying this is across the board by any stretch of the mediation, but often there is
someone that is oppressing that person. There's people in that person's life that are
causing or that are at cause for an oppressive situation. So, they are being suppressed in a lot of
different ways, and that could be actually a giant piece of the cause of their disease.
So, when you have struggles in your life, you do have to go, okay, is this coming from
people around me? Do I have a support system that's supporting my healing, or do I have people in my
life that are sucking the life out of me? Now, would I go through your genetics? Remember,
when I go through that one gene, that oxytocin gene? I don't have a picture of it here,
but that oxytocin gene, that if a person has a defect on that gene, because I'm saying this, because
many of my patients have a defect on that one oxytocin gene, that they produce a lot more oxytocin
than someone that doesn't have a defect on that gene, and I say the world would be a better place
if everybody had a defect on that gene, because oxytocin is a hormone-slash neurotransmitter
that increases your empathy for people. Well, that's a really good thing. I have a defect on that
gene, and I have a lot of empathy for people, but there's a big danger if the more you care
about people, the more you can attract people in your life that just kind of suck the limit
delights out of you. So, when you're dealing with a disease, and you're trying to get better,
make sure that you distance yourself healthfully from people that are drawing energy from you,
instead of giving energy to you. Now, I know that's difficult if that person is your spouse,
but you might need to have, you know, sometimes God's sovereignty allows you to get a disease
so that your spouse is confronted, I'm just saying, with the reality that they're not being a very
healthy person for you. So, you might need help with that, get counseling with that, get support for
that. If they're a friend in your life, you're best buzzer buddy, and they're not supporting whatever
decision you're making for your care, then they're not really your best buzzer buddy. A true friend is
going to support you even if they disagree with you. That's what a true friend does. A fake friend
only supports you if you do what they want you to do. That's not a real friend. So, it's difficult
whether you're a relationship with you, whether you're a sister or your child or something like that,
but this is where confrontation is necessary, you just need to say, hey, listen, honey, I love you
dearly, but you're not a good person to be in my life. I need people that support me. I need people
that love me. I need people that are sucking from me. And we need to just have a different
relationship. There was a real good book. I ran a number of years ago about different levels
of friendship. I can't remember the name of the book. I wish I did, but it talked about the most
intimate friend you have should be your spouse. And then a level two friend is someone that you share
a lot of deep things with and they support you no matter what. A level three friend is someone that
you would see in the grocery store and you'd stop and you'd talk to them for a half an hour about
what things are going on in their life. And a level four friend is somebody that you might wave to
in the parking lot because you remember them from PTA meeting, but that's all you really know them from.
Some people that are were considered level two friends for a long period of time need to move
down to a level three or a level four friend for you while you're healing. So don't ignore that
piece. Outside stress can be the devil's play toy in your life to bring you down. And you need to be
focusing on your relationship with God and deepening that and improving your health.
And then of course there's the spiritual attacks and that tends to be if you're a believer the most
common issue besides maybe better moral situations. And because the devil's constantly lying to you
and you see it all the time I mean he works through people and he works through this world and he
works through our mind both of all. And he typically tells us lies. So even if you're on this call
and you don't believe in the devil and well I don't believe in that voodoo stuff or that's crazy
you could call it whatever you want to call it I don't care. But I believe that we have an enemy
that's trying to get us down and the Bible is very clear that his purpose is to steal, kill,
a destroy. He's to steal our hope. He's to steal our life. He wants to take all our joy.
And he's what is to destroy our relationships destroy our relationship with God and to leave us alone.
And when he could get us alone that's when all hope seems gone and it's really easy to fall into
depression when we feel like we're by ourselves. And that is the thing that you want to guard against.
Those things that are made that you're listening to you got to make sure that they're coming from
the Lord and not coming from a depraved mind that we all have. We all have a fleshly heart. We all
have a fleshly mind. We all think bad thoughts. We all sin and fall short of the glory of God constantly.
But they God that his mercies are due every day and we can rely on those. So make sure you're not
listening to lies. And that's even lies about your your body and your health. That's even lies coming
from a doctor. Make sure you don't listen to me if I tell you things that aren't biblical.
Don't listen to people that don't that are telling you things that are
worldly. Don't listen to an ecologist that says you have X amount of months to live. How does he know?
It's just a lie. And you have to wipe those lies from your your brain in a really the only way that
you could do that is to just drown yourself in the truth. Because that's why we need to hold
every thought captive. We need that I'm not going to allow myself the luxury of a negative thought
because I can't afford that. I'm fighting a battle. So that's the battle front that you have to put
yourself in. And for me, I have to constantly remind myself who I am. That's why I gave you those
sheets, those packets of sheets in your three ring binder of who you are that you just Bible
verse after Bible verse to recite to yourself to copy down to put up on the board to tape on your mirror
to write on your on your windshield whatever you have to do to remind yourself over and over and over
and over and over over who you are in Christ. And that your victory has already been won not by anything
that you could do, but by what was done in the cross 2000 years ago, the victory is already yours. If
all you have to do is accept that. And I already win. I don't care how sick I feel. I don't care if
I am going to die tomorrow. I get to go be with Christ. I win. I already won. So it's not that's not
that's not the battle. The enemies just keep telling me that I'm trying to get me to fight the wrong
battle. The battle has already been won. And my battle that I face today is to hang on to the
victor who won my battle so long ago because I keep wanting to do this in my old work. And I forget
who I am in Christ. A really good book is who am I who I am in Christ by Neil Anderson if you want to
get it phenomenal book. Read it constantly. It's set up as a devotional, but you won't read it as a
devotional because you want to read it all in one day and read it every day. Great book just constantly
reminding you who you are in Christ and that the enemy is constantly trying to get you to forget that.
That's the battle that we have who we are our identity. If we could be rooted in our identity
in our true identity that God told us who we are then we just you know I don't worry anymore. I just
I just don't care anymore. A while back I had a sub but we had it's kind of an attack on our
clinic and I'll share it with you somewhat superficially. And this person you know was threatening us
and saying that he's going to that we're going to go to jail and all this kind of stuff in our clinics
going to be shut down and he was writing these evil letters to us and it was just downright
to muddick. And I won't lie it was shaking it was shook us and we did some things to be more
careful here and such and I'll remember a friend of mine said aren't you worried that this could
actually happen and of course in my flesh I'm worried. But then you go okay well why would I possibly
be worried? If my identity is rooted in Christ the better what worst thing think of the worst case
scenario that could happen I could die today I could have a heart attack while I'm speaking this
right now and drop dead. I win. I win no matter what because the victory has already been won.
So I the only reason why I'm here sharing with you now and the only reason why I continue to practice
than what I do is to bring him glory and by helping people to possibly bring him more glory that's
the only reason why we're here. It's not so we can play golf or there's no role play golf or so that's
what we could have a great floral okay. There's no role with having a floral okay but that's on our
purpose and where we forget when the enemy tricks us and forgets gets us to forget what our identity
is and our purpose is in here in life that it's really easy to get shaken by events that happen
whether it's bad news from the oncologist whether it's you know bad news from the IRS whether whatever
it is and it it's only human to get shaken so don't feel bad that you got shaken or that you're
less spiritual because you're in a sad time right now it doesn't mean you're less spiritual means you're
more human but then you need loved ones around you that just remind you of these things right now
that ground yourself in that identity look for a metabolic causes deal with circumstances in your
life that are getting you down and then get on your knees and pray because it is a battle and that's
what we're called to is this battle this battle of remembrance really of who we are a battle of
grounded ourselves in who we are and the only way I know to do that is to get in your Bible and read
of who you are and get on your knees and just ask for forgiveness and ask the Holy Spirit to show you
anything in your life that you need to change to to bring him more glory as he tells me all sorts of
things very gently very kindly no guilt no condemnation because there is no more condemnation for those
who are in Christ but he loves me enough to discipline me and he loves me enough to put me through trials
he loves me enough to put me through very very difficult times because he wants to refine me
and he wants to change me and he wants to make me more and more like the image of his son every
single day and if I'm not willing to go through that because it's painful oh it's it's not that I like
to but if I'm not willing to go through that then don't expect to be the warrior that you want to be
in the end so we go through pain we go through struggles we go through difficult times in life
because we live in a fallen world and it's to refine us to be more and more and more like
Jesus Christ every single day but remember you're not to do this alone that's what we're here for
you need to reach out to me that's what I'm here for for you that's what my staff's here for for you
that's what your church is there for that's what your loved ones are there for you don't do this alone
and that's what the enemy wants you to be remember I said before you wants to get you alone because
Eddie could beat the day like Tonya and you don't do this alone it's super important so that's
why preaching for today maybe this doesn't have anything to do with metabolic disease of cancer but
I think it has everything to do with our battle and even if you don't come from the same spiritual
perspective of me I think there's truth that you can gain from this little lecture and that you
can put into into everyday life and I believe that somebody maybe not anybody on this call but this
recording needed to hear this and we'll need to hear this and it's going to be a blessing that's
why I went through a bunch of oppression in my heart today and that's great so to get this information
out is super important so now I'm going to in that piece I'm going to unmute everybody and we are
going to ask questions so anybody have any questions and it doesn't have to be at any second that we
just shared maybe it's on your diet no okay then we're going to end this we'll keep it our time
we back on the same time next week unless something changes lord willing or if I get some crazy idea
this weekend post on the Facebook page we'll have this recording up on Facebook very soon and you
will be able to listen to the recording or share it with friends thank you very much should I pray
for a blessing for everybody this is quirky hi quirky hi I just wanted to tell you that that message was
absolutely awesome oh good that was a blessing for you yeah it was absolutely it was
oh good just wanted to say thank you for that oh yeah and I guess can I ask you a question about when
you know you those 10 sessions that I have yeah when do you think it would be a good idea that I come
for one as soon as you can so as soon as it works with your schedule you should schedule those okay do I
do all 10 of them at once or what will go like week by week we'll go like maybe one a week
is a session an all day thing or is it just oh you'll only be here about an hour or so okay well they're
having a benefit for me Sunday night so I think I'll come in one day week if that's okay absolutely
we'll be praying for that okay well thank you and I really appreciate that message it really helped
me a lot oh good yeah thank you you have a great day all right anybody else I just wanted thank you
to doctor Connors I I needed the message oh good and if you guys need any other support you know
don't don't listen to the devil adopt reach out to us okay all right love you guys thank you bye bye